buenos días steve cojan aquí pues hoy
voy a hablar sobre las tres etapas del
aprendizaje de idiomas de idiomas ahora
sabemos que el aprendizaje de idiomas
depende de la lectura y la escucha
depende de lo que se llama en inglés
country en sopó import es decir mensajes
comprensibles que nosotros recibimos a
través de la lectura y la escucha se
aprende las idiomas los idiomas a través
de este proceso no leyendo libros de
gramática no haciendo ejercicios en la
clase pero leyendo y escuchando bueno
para mí como a pendiente hay tres etapas
y esas etapas son distintas
las etapas o niveles de lo que se llama
el marco común europeo de referencia
para las lenguas que quitas que vosotros
sabéis que es una referencia para
evaluar una pendiente de lenguas de
idiomas pero para mí porque en este
marco común se habla siempre de usuario
básico usuario independiente para mí en
mi experiencia
las otras tres etapas son etapas de
adquisición del idioma entonces aquí
puntocom podemos entender lo que
escuchamos en lo que leemos este es lo
importante en la primera etapa no creo
no entendimos nada es ruido bueno y poco
a poco empezamos a hacer la distinción
donde acaba una palabra donde empieza
una palabra y poco a poco el ruido se
hace sentido o un parte de este ruido o
se hace sentido pero todavía no tenemos
la confianza que un día
de poder conquistar exprimirnos y
comprender entender este idioma es la
primera etapa la segunda etapa es cuando
ya podemos leer escuchar pero tenemos
que escuchar muchas veces la misma cosa
y si no leemos si sólo escuchamos no
entendimos pues es una etapa
cuando tenemos la confianza ya que un
día
la confianza de poder entender el idioma
la primera etapa quizás sean horas la
segunda etapa quizás 200 horas de las
200 horas
pero somos limitados a contenidos bueno
más sencillos de vez en cuando cosas más
interesantes más avanzadas pero sobre
todo de textos preparadas preparados
para aprenden test esa es la segunda
etapa y la tercera etapa es cuando
estamos libros podemos leer cualquier
cosa con dificultad con palabras que no
conocemos pero podemos y esta tercera
etapa es sin límite porque podemos
continuar
a mejorarnos en el idioma este hasta
bueno cuando queremos lo importante en
todo esto es mucha gente no logran a
progresar de la primera etapa hasta la
segunda etapa porque son frustrados de
la incapacidad de producir el idioma y
yo digo que este no es importante saber
producir el idioma al principio y cuando
vemos en este barco común el usuario
usuario que puede explicar o comentar
esto no es la verdad la verdad es que
necesitamos un nivel de comprensión
bastante alto para entonces poder hablar
en primero la comprensión a través de la
lectura y la escucha y después poder
hablar y si alguien sabe decir algunas
cosas y no entiende lo que dice el otro
este este no es una conversación por eso
yo digo que las tres etapas son etapas
de adquisición del idioma y tenemos que
ser pacientes y después la capacidad de
hablar y de usar utilizar el idioma bien
dra
bueno muchas mucho gusto y espero que
este ayuda en la adquisición del idioma
[Música]